the first slide that we have are the
easy ones i think we're going to pull
them up here in a second and basically
what uh
you highlight is just how much
electricity is actually used so just
maybe help us understand like it's not
nearly as much electricity as most
people think it is i mean it you know
it's all relative really that you know
and so this is taken from a paper i
wrote with nydeg called bitcoin nut zero
um and so we set out to sort of really
robustly quantify the electricity
consumption and also allow people to
sort of give them the tools to predict
the future electricity consumption
because the only people that have done
that historically have been like
wacky academics that get the numbers
wrong by like a factor of a thousand
so like there's this one paper from the
university of hawaii in 2018 that said
bitcoin was going to warm the earth by
two degrees
we appreciate your confidence in us but
we're not that i know they really like
really bitcoin maximalist to the core
right um and and their model was
premised on bitcoin having this per
transaction electricity cost which is
not how it works yep and also on bitcoin
transactions scaling up to hundreds and
hundreds of billions per year also not
really possible
so we want to present alternative models
that actually make sense okay so we have
that first one that uh if we pull it up
here it's simply just explaining that uh
it's only point two percent of all
global electricity generation and it's
.04 percent of global primary energy
consumption what's the difference
between global primary energy
consumption and global electricity
generation so the world produces a lot
more energy than it does electricity
because there are non-electric sources
of energy like
uh combusting fuels for transport
uh and uh you know
heating stoves yep that you might be
burning firewood or coal or something
like that
and so the amount of energy we produce
actually outstrips electricity so i
don't know you know it's sort of up to
you what you want to compare it to
whether you want to compare it to the
electricity that's produced on grid or
like the total you know energy this
world is producing which is a lot uh but
either way it's it you know
i i think it's relatively minimal for
you know a monetary system that stores
you know trillion dollars as of today
and settles you know tens of billions of
dollars a day
so really it's small regardless it just
depends what you want to compare it to
and i don't think the country level
comparisons make any sense because most
of the countries bitcoin is typically
compared to
are like small like pretty agrarian
countries that have like exported their
industrial sector to places like china
and so given that we live in a
globalized economy
no one country if you look within their
geographic borders like like emissions
factor of their gdp a lot of that can be
externalized like industrial centers
like china right so what you should be
doing is just looking at the industrial
impact of like whole industries and so
that's another thing we did in the paper
is we compared bitcoin to
uh certain industries certain sources of
load uh certain metal extraction so we
found that it was kind of in the same
universe as zinc
we have that slide next slide yeah look
at this yeah i think we got that one
i came prepared you know finally once
anyone ever protested over like the you
know electricity associated with the
zinc extraction somebody somewhere
probably once but that's it you know a
stupid question i'm sure someone's upset
about it
stop the zinc manufacturers i mean to be
clear zinc is a great metal like you
know supplementing zinc is like a good
idea in my opinion um but you know i
don't see anyone getting like
apoblectically upset about it um and
then of course bitcoin is actually
generally less than gold um kind of
probably less than copper the emissions
and then of course aluminum and steel
are like
massive
uh but yeah so like it compares with
kind of like niche metal extraction so
it kind of is what it is okay if we go
to the next slide here
we have this idea that uh it's not
digital gold to your opinion digital
aluminum so explain this yeah so i don't
know if have you guys visited any of the
big bitcoin plants
no there's this so there's one in uh
rockdale texas which is a really big one
um and then there's the other one i have
a picture here is in messina new york on
the saint lawrence river upstate new
york it just it's hard to get to we like
charted a little plane to get there um
those are former
alcoa smelting plants and aluminum you
know has the highest embodied energy
in the refining of the product of any
metal so for whatever reason smelting
bauxite and turning it into aluminum
takes a ton of electricity and so
because of that you had the smelters
would actually go to locations with
really abundant energy so they would
kind of chase the energy and so that's
why you'd end up with plants in like
upstate new york and things like that
with abundant hydropower
and aluminum ended up being this way to
export energy through the commodity and
now the amazing historical parallels the
bitcoin is kind of like that
uh bitcoin mines are now taking up
resonance in these old smelting plants
um and so you know i just really like
that historical parallel like aluminum
used to be this way to soak up excess
energy now bitcoin does that yeah and
bitcoin does it better
much more efficiently because bitcoin's
modular you can have one shipping
container with 500 asics out there on
the oil field you know soaking up excess
wasted gas
you can obviously do with hydro
you can you know and you can interrupt
the process which is very important
we'll get into that um so yeah it's just
as a synthetic metal basically it does
it in a sort of like highly efficient
you know highly granular way next slide
and then it's big like people don't
realize how big it is and actually i
think this number has been growing uh
pretty rapidly right in terms of how
much people are actually being paid to
secure the network right now it's bigger
than this already i made these slides uh
you know uh ten thousand dollars ago
[Laughter]
yeah it's a big industry though for sure
so right now uh if i just look quickly
approximately
51.52 million dollars over the last
couple of days is the mining reward that
globally is being paid out uh for those
that don't understand or don't know what
that means uh the bitcoin block subsidy
the thing that is given to miners every
10 minutes or so in exchange for them
helping to secure the network there's uh
adds up to 900 bitcoin per day you take
900 bitcoin per day and you multiply it
by uh the price and so over the last 24
hours that's 52.6 million dollars
according to
casebitcoin.com um all right let's go to
the next slide
by the way your title today on the show
is the most violent man in bitcoin
that's apt i really need to live up to
that
do it when you leave here
don't be violent right now other than
with your words
all right so with this uh i've now seen
multiple differences in this chart uh we
don't have the other one but uh there's
a chart that just came out that shows
that the us took majority of the market
share in china has zero we can talk
about why maybe china doesn't have zero
uh but definitely u.s has gained a ton
of market share china has lost a ton i
know and my regret is that i gave this
presentation a week before the new
cambridge data dropped so i have the old
chart on here but yeah suffice to say
the us is 35 percent of the network
today according to cambridge china is
apparently zero not actually zero
um cambridge couldn't wait to wipe them
out
oh china
yeah you're out of here um yes so
china's not actually zero but yeah
as i was pointing out here look bitcoin
mining us is the number one country in
the world we knew this even before the
cambridge data dropped now we know it
for sure
number one country in the world for
bitcoin mining that's a good thing
before the china ban of miners in may i
think it was what was the split between
the u.s and china do we remember in
terms of what the u.s market share was
at that time i mean it's on here the
historicals i mean the us was single
digits for a long time okay uh so very
very much not material uh china just
dominated they had you know 60 70
you know market share and and the us was
for a long time under 10 percent okay
today u.s has 35 which is the most out
of anyone so it doesn't mean that the
united states has majority it just means
that no other country has more than the
united states us at 35
now the two things that you call out
here that i think is really interesting
one is the new asic deliveries and what
i want you to explain is uh i don't
think people understand the lead time
for the machines and how basically when
somebody makes an order you know where
those machines are going and so you can
start to forecast out a little bit of
where hash rate's gonna come online you
know three four six months whatever it
takes for them to actually plug the
machines in yeah so knowing a little bit
about what the miners are doing you can
forecast the hash rate of the bitcoin
network in 12 months time and you can
forecast where mining will occur because
you the miners like to
you know announce that they've bought x
many units and that's promotional for
them so you just have to stitch all
those little pieces of data together and
you get a sense for where the where the
bitcoin network will be in 12 24 months
time obviously there's some uncertainty
in there so basically
um you know a lot of the i think the
best projections i've seen have the
bitcoin network being at 300 extra
hashes by the end of next year by the
end of next year and right now we're at
like what 150
yeah so doubling at least north of 300.
um if you looked at where the you know
new machines were going they were all
been bought by u.s buyers and a lot of
the buyers are public companies so
they're providing those disclosures on
ongoing basis we also know what
installations they're building in terms
of megawatts so we can get a pretty good
sense of where you know the industry is
going to be in a year's time uh and you
know it's the build-out is happening in
the u.s
where are they buying most of the
machines from is it still bitmain are
there other players that are now big
suppliers bitmain and what's minor micro
bt are the two big ones okay and of
those neither one are based in the
united states do we have concerns that
there is no actual like fabrication done
in the united states for the machines
yeah i think that's a concern um the
foundries are in i want to say korea and
taiwan obviously that's a big
geopolitical question if taiwan is going
to stay independent uh there is a
foundry being built by tsmc in austin i
believe and so they're trying to
diversify away i think they understand
the writings on the wall with taiwan
they want to kind of ship a lot of that
over it's going to take a while though
yeah and i guess part of this is if you
can get a fabrication facility built in
the united states you can one serve u.s
customers there's all kinds of kinds of
logistics that get solved there uh but
really it's probably the geopolitical
risk that they're solving for yeah i
mean there's a lot more important things
than not than making bitcoin chips um
you know like gpus i mean it just like
it's a critical industry um the us just
doesn't have a homegrown one right now
okay let's go to the next slide
this is uh the united states and in
texas now
i'll let you defend yourself but i don't
want you pandering to texas because
you're not in texas anymore
if you were given this presentation at
the texas blockchain summit i'm assuming
that they were expecting you say nice
things about taxes
explain why texas is so interesting well
yeah this is a texas that was the topic
they asked me to talk about so i wasn't
going to talk about bitcoin mining in
florida
[Laughter]
there isn't a lot when i saw this i
literally uh i saw somebody responded
online and they were like oh damn texas
is going to be huge i was like well yes
but this is also a texas-specific
conference look let's not write miami
and florida off we can still win this
okay we have currently approximately
zero amount of mining here in the great
state of florida and texas has a lot
they have a huge amount i mean i think
it's probably close to one gigawatt uh
keep in mind the whole bitcoin network
is approximately 10 gigawatts of power
so one tenth of the entire network is in
texas right now now that might be an
aggressive assumption but there's a huge
amount of build-out happening in texas
right now in particular west texas where
there's an enormous amount of renewables
and like the amount of renewables that
are coming on to the grid in the coming
years in texas is unbelievable i mean
unbelievable uh the the texas grid i
think is around 80 gigawatts uh ercot
and uh you're looking at you know maybe
20 30 gig watts of of wind and solar uh
just in the next two years you think
that 25 to let's call it 40 of the texas
grid is going to be used for bitcoin
mining oh no or is this net new edition
those are new renewables um my
projection is like two to three gigs uh
for bitcoin mining in texas by the end
of next year got it which i think is is
actually reasonably conservative based
on what's happening but yeah i mean so
that would be you know five-ish percent
of the grid maybe wow that's still a lot
it's helpful though it's it's you know
it's a very interesting source of load
uh it's a very kind of unique and
different source of load so there's you
know there's nuances there okay all
right let's go to the next
one i feel like we're playing a game of
like what's next because i forget what
we put in here okay all right so it's
becoming the
heartland of u.s mining let's go to
maybe the next one
and then this is how they're
aggressively expanding now most of this
is coming from publicly traded
uh disclosures yeah a lot of these are
public companies not all of them are
block streams not public um but yeah
core size about to go public will spack
probably the biggest they'll be the
biggest publicly traded miner in the u.s
riot is active in texas they're you know
pretty big
um you know compute north is building
down there in texas i mean like there's
just a huge amount of activity in the us
right now
you know if you're using you know modern
hardware you're mining your coins at
like five to ten thousand dollars right
now you sell the coin of fifty eight
thousand dollars so so you think that's
the price of sophisticated miners is
five to ten thousand dollars depending
on the energy cost and labor cost and
what you buy your machines at yeah but
keep in mind you have to depreciate the
value of the hardware i mean you have to
include the amortization of buying the
s19s and things like that um but yeah
like just on the pure
you know um meters that doubles the
price of the bitcoin on you know
including every single thing you
possibly could and now you're mining at
20 25 000 you're still selling it at 58
000. yeah the margins are obscene for
miners right now uh it's unreal and you
know the china crackdown created a huge
kind of surplus for the us miners china
gave a subsidy to u.s miners because it
was a big it's a single market yeah you
know it's not like some commodities
where they sell for different prices
like natural gas in the us is much
cheaper than natural gas in japan
but bitcoin sells for a single global
price and so if one country bans the
mining activity that's a subsidy to the
miners elsewhere it's incredible
so this is really interesting to me what
you're explicitly talking about is that
china shut down mining in their country
and that kicked off i don't know let's
say 90 to 95 percent of all the miners
in the country when they did that we saw
hashtag go down uh i think more than 50
percent is when it bottomed yeah uh and
they had to literally unplug their
machines move elsewhere we at that time
saw a bunch flow to the united states
also elsewhere but the united states was
definitely the biggest winner from that
when you get that drop in hash rate the
difficulty adjustment was pretty it was
i mean it was pretty breathtaking just
how quickly uh it recovered and was able
to kind of withstand what many people
would think of a normal computer system
could potentially be fatal right if 50
to 70 of all of your computing power
went offline in pretty much a moment's
notice
there's not many systems that are just
chilling right
and so the mining difficulty what did
that do to the profit margins of u.s
miners like how severe was the impact of
the profitability well it just made it
much easier to create a unit of bitcoin
i mean 50 easier um
and and so that drove up their margins
enormously uh and so that was like a
truly exogenous shock like people
weren't really expecting that uh and of
course it resulted in the destruction of
property you know tens of billions of
dollars of chinese miners because
frankly not all them could get their
monies out of the country yep a lot of
them are just sitting fallow in
warehouses in malaysia and places like
that so you know they weren't
necessarily as a cohort able to plug
them in elsewhere i mean you know many
like the capacity in the us is pretty
tight in terms of hosting capacity so
there just wasn't that much ability to
absorb
uh you know miners from sichuan
uh into the us yeah and so there's a
destruction of their property and that's
unfortunately the nature of living in a
you know command and control economy
where things can change like that yeah
but you know it benefited uh the u.s
miners enormously like a huge huge
amount
let's go to the next slide
uh so why texas is it just that hey they
love oil and gas and they've built it
out no i mean texas has some like pretty
unique features so the governor is pro
bitcoin uh both senators are now pro
bitcoin uh so we learned uh ted cruz is
incredibly smart about this stuff um i
don't know how he gained so much
expertise in the energy grid but he did
and it was very impressive okay so hold
on before you go on from that most
people i think have this view of ted
cruz which we got a sense
during the infrastructure bill stuff he
started to say some stuff that people
were like wait a minute like i agree
with ted cruz like that's not what i
thought he would be a position
then this conference i read you
transcribed some of his uh um his
comments
he sounds like he's actually more
informed than some people in the bitcoin
community like he was pretty legit do we
know where that came from i don't know
frankly i mean i haven't been in contact
with him to be clear uh but his
expertise his level of command of the
nature of ercot and uh the texan grid
and the specific interactions miners
have with the grid which i guess we can
get into
was like phd level
really and this guy has to have a
position on like hundreds of different
issues
so i'm like sitting there wondering like
wait how did he like get to that the
thing that most people would say doesn't
really matter that much but obviously he
thinks is a really big thing for texas
and the energy group yeah i mean it's
striking that he's put so much time and
effort into like really deeply
understanding this like what's a demand
response program what's a controllable
load resource like how does the supply
demand balancing operate on a grid how
do the miners you know come into that he
understands all that stuff um and so i
was pretty shocked by that i spent years
trying to figure it out
and ted you know just like coasts to the
front of the pack
all right so deregulated grid with
real-time spot pricing it kind of walk
us through like why is texas so suitable
yeah so erica is actually pretty
capacious well you keep saying erica
people don't know what that is sorry
ercot is shorthand for like the texas
grid basically um
they have a ton of excess renewables um
and i have a few slides i don't know if
we're going to do the whole presentation
we're not just 30 slides two minutes i
uh so i pump faked you like we go to
like slide 13 and then i just skipped
like three other ones
this is an important one okay you see
that wind corridor going from west texas
north to up to canada yep that's the
best area in the us to
uh you know mine your wind power right
why because it's windy okay
shocking that that is that is an amazing
insight i know it's really key don't
forget that that comes that'll be on the
test
um so then we have the southwest of uh
america has the best solar resources
okay and when in solar like you know the
capacity factor is in the the uptime is
like kind of low for both those
resources but in west texas you have
this conjugation of it's very windy and
it's very sunny and that means wow
amazing like suitability for renewables
that's why 30 of the texas grid today is
renewable and that's grown from like
five percent ten years ago
uh and so the problem is you've got 35
gigawatts of renewable
uh presence on the texan grid and it's
all in the northwest corner of texas but
all the load all the demand for energies
and kind of the southeast yep austin
houston
uh dallas and energy doesn't travel that
well that's the thing people don't get
about electricity you can't teleport it
you have to put it in these high voltage
transmission lines right
and they only have 12 gigawatts of high
voltage transmission lines from west
texas to the load centers so those are
full
and then what happens the rest of the
time and there's only five gigawatts of
load locally in west texas which is
mostly associated with oil extraction so
what do you do with the remaining like
15 gigs so time out for a second i just
want to uh
say this so that people at home
understand
wind and solar they suck in most places
because you can't do it 100 of the time
not remotely close to 100 of the time 25
to 40 okay
in the west part of texas very
specifically it's hot and sunny and it's
windy so you basically can do wind and
solar much more than you can do other
places but the problem is that the
people who need the electricity are far
away in the other part of the state and
so the ability to transport it there you
basically can't put any more through
that transportation because it's already
full
and then we say well why don't you just
use it right there on site all of the
normal uses for electricity that's also
spoken for and so now you basically have
created all this additional
energy but you don't know what to do
with it and keep in mind they're going
to be doubling the quantity of renewable
energy produced mainly in west texas
in the coming years this is the part of
the conversation where like bitcoin
shows up with like a superman cape and
is like here to save the day because it
can do what i mean it can it can absorb
that excess of stranded energy um and
like if you don't use the energy it just
gets pumped into the ground you know um
and actually you see this if you look at
a map of prices in texas the left you
know the western half
is often negatively priced the energy
producers will pay people to take the
energy away from them
and the right half you know is where
it's actually expensive so bitcoin is
kind of this sponge which soaks up the
excess
and you know that's incredibly useful
for these renewable producers because
now they have a second buyer of energy
initially they just had one buyer which
is the grid and the grid would only buy
it on its own terms
now there's a second independent
you know uncorrelated buyer which means
they can monetize these assets at you
know interesting times and they have the
choice who they're going to sell to so
that makes the economics their core
business much much better uh and so you
know some people say like okay well
bitcoin is not an incentive to build new
renewables you know maybe that's that's
fine but like it's certainly a way to
monetize existing renewables and make
their payback cycles much faster and
that really matters in the energy
landscape and it feels like uh we're
just talking about renewables and
there's persistent demand from bitcoin
which is a huge piece of this and that's
where you're getting into well sometimes
i actually want to sell to the bitcoin
network because i know what i'm going to
get paid there but also there may be a
spike in need on the energy grid or cot
and i may get paid more than i would
even make with bitcoin and so i may
offload but i now have choice and when i
have choice it allows me to better
optimize my business based on the
current factors absolutely and what's
more is the miners opt into these
programs where the grid operator tells
them hey you want you want to turn off
your machines for a little bit so that
all the power can go to households that
need it the most so when you have
scarcity on the grid the miners turn
themselves off they actually get paid to
do this
uh and so
they are not depriving anyone of energy
they are actually
uh monetizing the energy assets most of
the time and during an energy crisis or
period of scarcity they're off
and so all that energy
goes to households in hospitals you know
to whatever run air conditioning so you
know that's a really important thing
there are formal programs on the texas
grid that miners are perfectly suitable
for and other industrial centers of load
are not because virtually nothing else
can turn itself off at short notice like
that bitcoin miners can turn themselves
down or off within seconds
so they can deal with the
interruptability uh aluminum smelting
you know factory can't or you know a
grain processing facility can't turn
itself off uh you know commercial real
estate can't just turn itself off like
that so miners are this unique flexible
load that's really suitable for a grid
like that where if the grid is really in
high demand there's energy scarcity they
can just be off
okay let's go to the gas flare capture
uh if we keep going matt to uh next one
here
explain what gas flare capture is and
why this is so powerful for the miners
and also from an environment standpoint
so this is truly off-grid mining so in
the case of mitigating flared gas
you're actually just not on the grid at
all and so the way oil extraction works
is whenever you get oil out of the well
it comes up in a mixture of oil and gas
so
you're actually not just getting oil
you're getting oil and gas oil is the
thing you want gas is generally treated
as kind of a waste product and
oftentimes with a lot of these wells
you're not connected to pipelines so you
don't have a way to take the gas away
there's no economic use for it so what
they actually do is because methane is
pretty bad for the environment they
combust it which has the output of
carbon dioxide and the carbon dioxide is
what is released post combustion so
that's the flaring like you know if you
look at an image of like oil derricks
like you'll see the flares right
the flaring is like pretty inefficient
doesn't burn that well
uh some of the methane isn't combusted
so what the miners do instead is they
take this waste product natural gas they
put in a generator and they burn it in a
more complete combustion process and
they mine bitcoin with the with the
electricity um and so like that is a
dramatic improvement over the status quo
and so people look at this they don't
like it because you know they see miners
that are using natural gas but the thing
to understand is the natural gas was
going to be combusted anyway
there was no economic use for it on site
there was no way to get it to a market
right it just wasn't worth it natural
gas is pretty cheap in the us really
really cheap so it's not worth building
a pipeline infrastructure to take it
away and i guess the other last thing to
note is like when you do what's called
initial production on oil well so you
you sort of initially start it up
there's oftentimes like a six-month
burst of natural gas
and there typically wouldn't be the
ability to you know accommodate that gas
and get it to market so
the bitcoin miners in this case come in
take advantage of that and you know they
might leave in in six months time so
it's it's a remarkably like flexible
uh and you know potentially short-term
relationship
most of the companies i know that are
doing this are bitcoin mining companies
going to the gas flare companies the
companies are flaring gas
are we have we seen the reverse have we
seen any of those people say hey why
don't we just become the experts and
like vertically integrate
yeah so um
i believe upstream data do not actually
do the mining themselves they create the
gensets and the units for energy
asset owners to mine themselves on a
proprietary basis
so
i think you'll see more of this too
frankly
i think we're going to see in the next
few months energy companies actually
get into this space on a primary basis
as opposed to contracting out with
miners agreed uh and if we go to this
slide right here we're talking about the
gas flare uh carbon negative uh this to
me
puts us into the realm of uh bitcoin is
preventing climate change is it solving
climate change is it uh
having a hand in presenting a solution
or a potential solution like how do you
think about bitcoin gas flare capture
and then this whole climate change
debate and uh and kind of effort that's
underway i mean it's certainly in the
context of the flare gas mitigation is
making climate change no worse okay uh
so it's not contributing more to the
problem at a minimum because the gas is
flared regardless that's just a
byproduct of hydrocarbon extraction and
we still need oil for cars and airplanes
and boats and things like that so we're
not going to be able to wean ourselves
off of that anytime soon so during this
transition phase where we still use
hydrocarbons
um you know there's gonna be this
externality of natural gas that's
unquestionable the miners can deal with
it in a way that has a lighter climate
impact than the default way which is
flaring or venting frankly
uh and and if you're flaring on a windy
day most of it's vented anyway so
by controlling the reaction by coming
and piping the oil into a generator
uh and you know combusting in a more
controlled way you're mitigating the
emissions that's the chart of halfway
with crusoe energy
uh and so you know that's that's a net
improvement for sure i'm gonna let my
brothers ask questions about mining in a
second but uh if you have to think about
how important this is for the united
states moving forward what we see going
on in texas obviously is pretty
impactful is this something where other
states and cities will start to
replicate this in a material way or is
it specific to that environment because
texas has the renewables it has the the
kind of energy grid aspects that we've
been talking about no i mean i think
we're going to see it being relevant for
nuclear we're already seeing nuclear
providers partnering up with bitcoin
miners because again just having an
uncorrelated buyer improves your core
economics
and you know nuclear runs all the time
but the grid demand is like a sine wave
right and so
at night you know energy might be really
cheaply priced and so what if you could
monetize your nuclear output at night by
selling to bitcoin instead of selling to
the grid
uh and you know that would improve your
economics and improve your payback
periods you know that might give you a
better incentive to build more nuclear
so
uh it goes far beyond just wind and
solar
we know bitcoin is mined with hydro as
well
but yeah it's a pressure it's an
economic pressure on the grid which i
think uh you know liberates some of
these like stranded or underutilized
assets